let us look at the major events in the
week 3 of embryonic development the most
important event at the beginning of this
third week is the formation of primitive
streak this is a thickening containing
the midline groove forms along the mid
sagittal plane of the embryo and it
defines the Primitive body axis the
cranial and The Cordial end the second
most important event is the gastrulation
where the AP blast give rise to three
different germ layers at around day 16
first definitive endoderm forms then the
intrambryonic mesoderm forms and lastly
the ectoderm forms then around day 17
the notochord starts forming
and notochord is really important for
vertebrates at the end of this week
there would be formation and induction
of the neural tube a portion of the
ectoderm becomes the neuro ectoderm
eventually it would give rise to the
entire central nervous system and
thereby it marks all the four major
events in the week 3 of embryonic
development